hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here to ask you if you kept your
promise and you may be wondering what
promise I'm talking about but oddly
enough in the beginning of May I'm
talking about your new year's resolution
because I can tell you if you're
starting to get panicking you're like oh
god I didn't do it well don't worry
because I'm here to confess that I
myself fell off the wagon if you didn't
know my original goals were to be in
best shape of my life to learn guitar
and to learn German the fitness goal
like maybe it was vanity that I wanted
to do it I noticed I was getting a
little bit of a belly and I wanted to
just be in general shape which is a
cliche for new year's resolutions guitar
was just because I played trumpet in
high school and I know all the stuff
about music and I wanted to get back
into music and I've always wanted play
guitar
so I wanted to do that just to get
caught up in that world again and then
language German is because my last name
is Fishbach and that's a very German
last name and I thought it would be
appropriate to actually know the
language instead of having people
constantly ask me if I speak German and
telling them no and unfortunately I have
failed in all aspects of those things
and I know the years not over yet but in
the middle of May I thought I would be
at least somewhere close to my goals and
I started to realize why I was failing
and I could make whatever excuse I
wanted I could make the excuse if I
didn't have time or I got distracted or
things got in the way but generally
speaking I realized that I failed in my
goals because I didn't think of the
long-term aspects of what I was trying
to do because for fitness I wanted to be
in the best shape of my life just
because I had vain reasons in mind and
that's good in by itself but in terms of
being in shape that's not really a end
goal type thing because if you work to
be in shape and then you get to be in
shape and then you stop like there was
no point in you doing it in the first
place you're just going to get back out
of shape again that's a life long
thing you need the proper motivation
behind it and I started to realize after
I had a little bit of a health scare
again nothing is wrong I'm totally fine
but I live in this state where I have to
get routine checkups to make sure that
my tumor that I had before I started
YouTube I have to get checked to make
sure it doesn't come back again and when
I was getting my checkup there was
something they found and I had to get it
checked more thoroughly just spare you
the grisly details but it turned out to
be fine
there was nothing but that's something
that I have to be mindful so when I
originally went after my goal of getting
into shape just because I wanted to look
good I failed to realize that I wanted
to live healthier because I never know
if the tumor that I had is going to come
back and I can increase my odds by
exercising and eating better and
hopefully it'll never come back but you
never know with these things and and
with fitness like it's a lifelong goal
and with language and music I think I
was misguided in what I wanted because I
didn't have an end goal in mind I didn't
have something that I really wanted to
do with those talents I didn't have
something like I didn't know if I wanted
to perform with guitar or some reason
that I was trying to impress someone
with guitar and with language I didn't
really have an end goal for speaking
German the other than that it would have
been cool to be able to do that but as
far as the language goes I actually
recently realized something that was
very very important to me I I talked
about my family in Korea a lot I talked
about them like unending I have a lot of
family in Korea I have numerous aunts
and uncles I have actually seven on and
I have numerous cousins and a lot of
them are very proud of what I've managed
to accomplish on YouTube and especially
my grandma who I love to death but
recently
my grandma had a stroke and she's doing
okay now but this is actually her second
stroke and to be perfectly honest and to
put it bluntly I don't know how much
longer she's going to be okay you know
like it's grim to think about I and I
hope she lives quite a bit longer but
she's getting older and this is her
second stroke and the first one that she
had left her a little bit disabled and I
have all this family that I talk about
all the time and I love very dearly but
I've never talked to them and that's a
weird thing to say it's a weird thing to
admit I have all this family this huge
supportive family that is so proud of
what I've done and that loves me and my
mom is associated with that and she's
here in America but they're all over in
Korea and that maybe two or three of
them speak English the rest of them just
be Korean and some of them speak
Japanese but not many of them speak
fluent English to carry a conversation
and it dawned on me that my grandma that
I love very dearly
I've never had a conversation with her
like I've never really had the chance to
talk to her and discover like her life
and where she's come from and the
struggles that she had when she came
down from North Korea right before the
war and the border went down my grandpa
who who has passed on and my grandma
they abandoned everything they had they
had lands they had money but he was all
going to get taken away from them so
they just picked up left their entire
family and ran down south and right now
they live outside of Seoul and a lot of
you guys are scared because the the
situation in Korea seems to be dire but
my family is done in South Korea right
now and I don't know how to talk to them
you know so with that in mind that is
now my reason why I want to learn Korean
and combined I started to realize that
if I take away the things that I want
for just pure vanity and have an end in
mind for and I take on the things that I
want to do as lifelong challenges and
lifelong beneficial skills that I will
have because number one I will live
healthier and hopefully live longer
enough to be able to do the things that
I want to do and number two learn Korean
to be able to speak with my family who
supports me and loves me and hopefully
I'll be able to visit Korea again
because some of you may not know I'm
half Korean I don't know if anyone
actually like there are always some
people that are shocked to discover that
I'm half Korean but yes I'm half Korean
and I'm half German and I want to be
able to talk to my family and I want to
be able to talk to my grandma yeah and I
want to be able to help my mom who is
bilingual she speaks perfectly fluent
english and perfectly fluent Korean and
I want to help her because she's
starting to forget a little bit of the
Korean because she doesn't have anyone
to talk to in Korean and I want my
brother to be able to do the same thing
so these are the reasons why I've kind
of refocused what I've wanted and if I
had to wrap this up in a message for you
guys I wanted to tell you guys but it's
okay to fall off the wagon so long as
you pick yourself back up and reevaluate
why you fell off and then refocus and
hop back on them because it's like it's
hard to just constantly get back up and
not change anything of your approach to
it but in this year and what I've wanted
to do I've realized it's so easy to stop
when you when you think there's an end
in mind and that applies to anything
outside of this like what I do here on
YouTube if I thought there was an end
like I wouldn't keep pushing forward and
keep hitting it every day because I
wouldn't want there to be an end and I
would think about that all the time and
I would think of a foe when am I going
to stop this thing when am I gonna stop
it like this and what I do on the
internet and what I do in terms of
creation and it may not always be
YouTube videos but what I do in terms of
creation and giving doing the charity
streams I do
because it's a lifelong venture for me
and I may have an audience or I may have
not not have an audience or like I may
be speaking to an audience of 10 people
I may be speaking to an audience of a
million people like it doesn't matter
because for me that creation is a
lifelong journey of self-discovery and
learning and and going forward and
trying new things always always trying
new things and exploring new territory
and that is so fun and I'm just you know
I'm always grateful that you guys are
here along for the ride for as long as
you want to be here but my advice to you
is look for the things that really
really mean something to you and use
those as fuel to carry you on to your
goals and that that right there that is
going to change everything because I can
guarantee you now that I've focused in
on what I really wanted what matters to
me
and I can still do guitar as a hobby but
I don't until I find some reason to
really really really pursue it like
until I find the reason I'm going to
shelve that and I'm going to focus on
fitness for my own sake and in language
for my family's sake and that really
does music so anyway I just wanted to
share that with you guys I hope you guys
are having a wonderful Monday I've got a
lot of cool stuff I really am thrilled
at the response you guys had -
markiplier TV we worked really hard on
that one and I'm just I'm just tickled
to death that you guys loved it and you
can expect a lot more from the
characters that you saw in that video
because we put them in the same room for
a reason
and I think you guys are discovering it
very soon and you will see it in the
future so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you think
down the comments below and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye